so BLM let me read their mission state
to mission statement to you okay right
right from their website it says we are
guided by the fact that all black lives
matter regardless of actual or perceived
sexual identity gender identity gender
expression economic status ability
disability religious beliefs or
disbeliefs immigration status or
location we make space for transgender
brothers and sisters to participate and
lead we are self reflexive and do the
work required to dismantle cisgender
privilege and uplift black trans folks
especially black trans women who
continue to be disproportionately
impacted by trans antagonistic violence
we build a space that affirms black
women and is free from sexism misogyny
and environments in which men are
centered we practice empathy we engage
comrades with the comrades actually say
comrades we engage comrades with the
intent to learn about and connect with
their contexts to learn about and
connect with their contexts you know I
just want to connect with your context
that sounds vaguely sexual doesn't it
it sounds very euphemistic we make our
spaces family-friendly and enable
parents to fully participate with their
children we dismantle the patriarchal
practice that requires mothers to work
double shifts so that they can mother in
private even as they participate in
public justice work we disrupt the
Western proscribed nuclear family
structure by supporting each other as
extended families and villages that
collectively care for one another we
foster a queer affirming Network when we
do we we do so with the intention of
freeing ourselves from the tight grip of
heteronormative thinking or rather the
belief that all in the world are
heterosexual we cultivate an
intergenerational and communal network
free from ageism we believe that all
people regardless of age show up with
the capacity to lead and learn okay so
and that's just that's
part of it okay so we're talking about
trans people we're talking about
actually program an awful lot about
trans people for some reason we're
talking about sexism we're talking about
the patriarchy we're talking about
unfair working conditions we're talking
about ageism we're talking about
disrupting the nuclear family we're
talking about getting rid of
heteronormative thinking we're talking
about cisgender privilege and then
elsewhere on the website also says
they're focused on environmental
injustice economic injustice access to
health care access to quality education
voting rights voter suppression sounds
like fourteen things I think fourteen or
fifteen and that's just a sampling it is
a veritable cornucopia of issues that
they are talking about mostly far-left
issues often extremely far left issues
dismantling the nuclear family
heteronormative thinking this is far far
far far left a bunch of stuff that you'd
expect you know a white girl in a Gender
Studies class to care about if you
polled the average black person in
America if you got a you know if you had
a thousand black people pulled it random
do you think that they would cite these
as high priorities in their lives are
these the things they're waking up
worried about and focused on cisgender
privilege and heteronormative thinking
the average black person of you if you
were to ask them well you know what what
are the things that most important you
how many are gonna say dismantling
cisgender privilege how many of the
average white person is gonna answer
that way the answer is it's almost none
now
conducted this poll but i
that's-that's-that's I think a very fair
assumption because these are the goals
and and desires and priorities of
far-left political activists and yet
amid all of these issues despite the
extremely wide lens that BLM is is using
here they can't make room anywhere on
the website to even mention the problem
of black children being slaughtered in
the street by criminals they've got time
to talk about cisgender privilege yet
somehow cisgender privilege is a is a is
a bigger affront to black lives and to
the dignity of black life than black
children being killed in the street in
carjackings they have no space for that
they have no space for the thousands of
other black people who are killed every
year they don't mention it doesn't come
up anywhere ever the sad fact of the
matter is that black lives matter is a
very necessary message because black
lives are indeed devalued and discarded
on a routine basis in this country but
that devaluing and that discarding is
happening almost all of the time in the
vast vast majority of cases within the
black community itself there is no
getting around that and the murder rate
is not the only evidence of that I want
you to watch this video I'm gonna play
this for you and it's gone sort of viral
over the past few days it's actually
from I think 2019 and it shows a young
black guy with two other young black
people in the car one of them his sister
apparently and then someone else and
he's flaunting his guns and he's saying
that he's gonna kill a cop if he gets
pulled over just just watch this let's
take flight
[Music]
I will keel you know as well let me go
do to him you know I will kill you okay
now think about what you just saw there
that that is a young guy who is
apparently totally willing to throw his
own life away for no reason he's
according to his own words he is
prepared to die for no reason he's ready
to shoot at a cop instigate a fatal
encounter
the best-case scenario go to jail for
the rest of his life for no reason just
you know why not no reason other than
bravado and acting out the stuff that he
hears in songs like the one that's
playing in the background during the
video black lives matter
yeah they do but tell him that he
doesn't know that that guy I know I'm
sure he would shout the slogan but he
doesn't even think his own life matters
his own life he is this is a a
self-imposed devaluing of his own life
that he is doing he's willing to die
just because just to impress some people
on Instagram or Facebook whoever that
video was was streaming this is the same
attitude the Rashard Brooks had he he
instigated a fatal encounter with cops
for just why because he didn't want to
go to jail for because you know he was
he was gonna go to jail for DUI
okay well now now best case scenario
you've just you've just gone from your
getting a DUI charge to about seven
other felony charges that's best case
scenario if you survive which he didn't
that's ray
Shard Brooks who did not think his own
life mattered certainly not enough to to
take basic steps to preserve his own
life and this is the attitude that cops
in the city run up against all the time
it is a very noxious and virulent kind
of nihilism which treats violence and
even death as a game and this is what
cops are confronting in the inner cities
across the country if your black lives
matter movement is if you're the cops
are confronting us if your black lives
matter movement is not confronting this
and not addressing it and not fighting
against it and not exposing it then your
black lives matter movement is nothing
but a fraud nothing but a front which is
what BLM is now I want you to imagine
just think about for a moment the
situation that a the average black child
in in this in a in you know the average
inner city is facing okay he's growing
up in a home without a father he listens
to music and consumes media that
explicitly glorifies and advocates
violence murder and crime in you know of
course it's like it's cliche to even
talk about that or cliche but also I
guess racist to talk about that or you
know you're it's offensive somehow but
this is a stuff that kids in the city
not just in the city across the country
but listening to is it openly advocating
say oh yeah go out get yourself killed
so no father in the home consuming media
that explicitly glorifies navigates
violence crime and murder living in a
community where murder murder is a daily
occurrence in Chicago it is a daily
occurrence in Baltimore is a daily
occurrence
drug dealers rule the streets that's the
situation he's in what honest person
could look at that and decide that the
police are the biggest problem
you you really think for that black
child that the biggest problem for him
is the police that's where all this goes
back that's the source of most of his
troubles that's the thing most likely to
kill him no not even close so the whole
thing is ludicrous
and it is it's a shame that you know
that there is that there is something
called the black lives matter movement
that doesn't actually care about black
lives because we could we could use a
real black lives matter movement this
video is sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description